hey how did you know I was here I saw
you from my window that's where I live
by the way not that you ever asked what
are you doing I went to all the places
where I dumped trash earlier and cleaned
it up so they couldn't be traced back to
me
well it looks like you cleaned up
everything you're doing this because you
feel bad and you're not even doing it to
get me to help you anymore because I
told you that's not gonna happen okay
yeah fine I felt bad for stupid Gunnar
and stupider Antonio and the whole
neighborhood I felt bad about what I did
was a weird feeling not used to it
didn't love it feeling remorse about
being wrong isn't as good as just doing
something right but it's a start look I
think you're capable to change and I
will help you try oh wow man I swear I
won't let you down
hi there I've collected the worst
smelling garbage that I could find do
you still want me to dump it inside of
Antonio's house what no I did not tell
you to do that you are loco girlfriend
okay I won't let you down starting now
[Music]
you